welcome to cooking potatoes a hundred
different ways where sometimes things
can get a little messy today we're
making potato puff balls this is a
simple recipe that calls for mashing
baked then cold potatoes then adding
potato starch black pepper cumin and
salt once everything is mixed the dough
is rolled into cute balls then fry to
Golden Perfection but we later found out
that some tweaks were needed
like swapping potato starch for cooked
semolina flour to prevent fireworks and
potato farm from happening I rate this a
6 out of 10. the texture on the inside
reminds me like squid balls or fish
balls that's good you can find the full
non-exploding recipe on tasty.com